alors à la castonguay montréal chantal
hébert à toronto michels et aux jets à
montréal bonsoir messieurs dames
parfois nous avions nous parlions peu
plus tôt dans le bulletin d'une
conférence de presse de thomas mulcair à
montréal dont ils sont tous ils arrivent
tous à montréal est un débat important
demain à tva on va en parler dans une
seconde mais d'abord parler - de
monsieur mulcair qui l'a doit monter le
ton aujourd'hui on a senti une nervosité
on nous disait que on voulait même pas
qu'on ait mourani donne une entrevue
c'est vous dire le haut et [ __ ] on se dit
quoi en ce moment il faut changer l'air
de la pièce
il faut trouver il faut augmenter la
pression sur monsieur harper alec
castonguay
j'étais ce matin mois à l'annonce de ta
maman lequel les dirigeants du npd parce
qu'on va se faire d'ici la fin de la
campagne c'est de rappeler aux électeurs
qui sont quand même très très nombreux à
vouloir du changement nous regardant des
sondages au québec les proportions
atteignent presque 75 % des québécois
qui disent qu'on doit changer de la
couleur du gouvernement la réplique on
ne vote pas le 19 octobre uniquement sur
le niqab et qui a évidemment 80 de
gouvernance qui vont avec un vote et
qu'on va parler davantage
d'environnement on va se parler du
commerce international notamment
partenaire transpacifique pour être
signé cette semaine qu'on va leur parler
de tout ce que les québécois 1 - de
stephen harper dans les dernières années
pour leur écoute et il touchait aussi
dans la balance si 19 octobre
y'a pas uniquement l'histoire du niqab
ce qu'on va arriver à changer la façon
dont le débat se déroule depuis deux
jours on verra mais c'est clairement
l'objectif que poursuivent et thomas mon
coeur ce matin et ça va s'accentuer dans
les prochains jours chantelle vous êtes
dans l'équipe du npd vous vous dites
quoi là aujourd'hui je me serais dit
déjà une semaine ou deux
j'ai un problème et le problème
fondamental et on y revient en écoutant
le scalène a entendu c'est oui c'est
vrai plus les sondages vont montrer et y
en a deux aujourd'hui qu'il montre que
les conservateurs pourraient être en
piste pour former un gouvernement dans
le moment minoritaire mais quand même
c'est significatif de ce qui se passe
plus les gens qui veulent le changement
vont se dire il faut faire quelque chose
ils vont probablement cessé de se
préoccuper de sujets un petit peu plus
un petit peu plus marginaux par rapport
à qui veut gouverner pendant quatre ans
le problème de monsieur mal car c'est
toujours le même c'est que dans le
moment il n'est pas en train de gagner
le reste du canada avec un problème
québécois il réussit pas à s'imposer en
ontario où il est bon troisième
et plus les sondages vont montrer qu'il
est bon troisième au canada et bons
troisièmes en ontario plus les gens qui
veulent le changement mais on peut se
dire oui comment vainqueur un bon
argument on veut pas avoir ce qu'ils ont
appris pendant quatre ans mais est ce
que c'est le bon véhicule pour arriver à
nos fins exactement
michel et parce que leur sort va
peut-être rebondir cette volonté de
plusieurs électeurs de changer les
choses mais il faut qu'il choisisse un
véhicule et comme dit chantal le
véhicule du npd perd de la vitesse
le principal problème monsieur bancaire
version de maintenance et le vote
stratégique si vous voulez changer
gouvernement ce que vous votez encore
pour le parti qui est au troisième rang
pour contrer ça il doit absolument
montrer qu'au québec le vote stratégique
peut aller à 8 kg au québec
il a encore sa base qui est loin d'être
ça fait quand on regarde la vitesse à
laquelle il a descendu là ça semble peu
stabilisé alors ses conseillers disent
en fait descendre la journée de
l'allergie sportive pour revenir dans le
match
il faut frapper un circuit pour frapper
des circuits roues aux débats de tva il
faut en frais payés à tout le monde en
parle dimanche soir faut vraiment qu'ils
se remettent dans le match pas évident
de faire ça parce que dans on le sait
dans la plupart la plupart du temps
quand il ya des débats comme ça c'est
très rare que quelqu'un réussit à se
démarquer de façon de façon aussi
absolue
frappé un simple puis c'est bien beau
mais ça n'est pas convié le point à
l'autre équipe
wizishop secourir revendiquer quand même
un droit d'auteur sur la métaphore de
baseball parce que c'était la conclusion
de ma chronique de ce matin en star sur
le npd je les sors du cheval jouanno
avant que le npd sans m'en parler en
face une ligne que je veux quand même en
revanche ceux qui paient le droit
d'auteur c'est tellement que je fais dit
et je partirai en plus sur le base-ball
auquel je connais pas grand chose la
séquence des lodges mais cherche un jet
à bordeaux la lugeuse roumaine qu'avec
avait deux qui avait deux prises contre
lui la première étant justin trudeau qui
arrive au débotté vo avec de l'élan plus
depuis lundi la cause de son débat mais
ces bons chiffres dans les sondages et
ça écrit partout là on n'a rien eux des
compliments
les fleurs peut-être le pot s'en vient
mais des chroniqueurs à toronto sur la
performance en campagne de justin
trudeau
la deuxième c'est que monsieur wenger
s'en va aux débats il s'envoie tout le
monde en parle dimanche et aux deux
endroits on peut s'attendre à ce qu'on
lui parle du niqab
très bien mais parlons ses courbes
parlons-en de ce débat alec des bottes
de main essentiellement pour l'auditoire
québécois pas uniquement mais
essentiellement pour lui l'histoire
québécois la racontez moi c'est que
chaque chef doit faire parce que on dit
à chaque fois que c'est important mais
c'est important c'est des bonnes d'abord
ça se frappe des coups de circuit même
si des fois nous les observateurs on l'y
voit pas on a l'impression que c'était
au mieux un doute temps en temps elle
franchit la guerre et leur fille la
clôture qu'on l'a pas vu jack layton
c'est ce qui s'est passé la dernière
fois en 2008 il y avait eu un plus tôt
en 2011 est plutôt un bon débat alors
qu'on n'avait rien vu de significatif
souvenez-vous de françois legault québec
qui avait relancé sa campagne avec le
débat tv hockey celui ci avait été
plutôt efficace donc ça arrive ceci dit
il faut des circonstances particulières
on verra justement mon coeur mais c'est
clair que lui ça et prend ça et prend
des bons des bosses elle prend une bon
passage à tout le monde en parle justin
trudeau lui qu'on attend ça fait déjà un
petit bout de combattants qui ce qu'il
se plante à un débat qu'il s'enfarge lui
même
ça s'est pas produit puis je pense que
les chefs attendait beaucoup de justin
trudeau en le laissant parler à nouveau
faire des gaffes par lui-même il va s'en
charger ça arrivera paul donc faudrait
changer sa stratégie du côté des
adorateurs du justin trudeau peut-être
la tête
un peu plus que ce qu'on a fait depuis
le début parce que visiblement il fait
pas de garde par lui-même
stephen roth haut niveau ce qu'ils
soient très très très calme il est
toujours très cadre d'un débat en france
est presque effacé mais il répète ses
lignes par le public très ciblé ça va
probablement la même chose puis je lui
dis certes qui bon débat ok mais tu es
bon celui de jeudi dernier à radio
canada va probablement être aussi
efficace mais là je pense que thomas
voeckler va devoir peut-être un petit
peu plus
je voudrais pas efficace le même petit
peu plus peut-être incisif enfin je dis
c'est bon le beaucoup laisser aller la
dernière fois allez y est redevenu un
joueur dans certaines circonscriptions
plutôt maman qu'elle devra s'en
préoccuper et ce que le gilles duceppe
chantal et michel g duceppe doit avec
ces débats et lui ou s'il sera tout le
monde en parle l'autre semaine mais la
différence est en 0 députés et deux
trois députés où en trouver rome c'est
la survie pour l'instant d'abord si on
peut dire un mot sur stephen harper
parce qu'on n'en parle jamais c'est
quand même eu deux parties étant monté
alors sa performance de débord pas
diluer nuire et au québec où il ya eu
une remontée après le débat comme dans
la gazette du canada où ses appuis se
consolident mais dans lequel monsieur
duceppe
effectivement dans le moment malgré
cette modeste remontée est quand même en
dessous de son score de 2011 exemple il
y avait remporté quatre sièges
exact michel je ne sais pas dans la zone
payante mais il va lancer au aucun des
trois autres partis et dans la zone pays
vraiment dans la zone payante
actuellement il ya que le npd qui est
malgré qu'il ait perdu beaucoup de voix
alors pour monsieur rapports entre
autres c'est très important d'arriver
dans cette zone où on peut vous savez il
ya ces cinq comtés dans la région de
québec dans les bois-francs mai
peut il peut gagner d'autres comtés il y
en a déjà gagné 11 au québec ça peut
s'étendre cette petite région là qui
devient un peu plus grande de votre
conservateur lui aussi donc doit avoir
un bon débat est aussi trudeau soyons
clairs il a un peu négligé le québec
depuis le début de la campagne il faut
venu très souvent cela désavantage que
il est il est pas lui non plus et fort
au niveau payant il n'y a pas encore
assez de votes de voix pour que ça
devienne payant un siège mais avec un
bond des boys pourrait dépasser 7
cette marque est là autour de 25 26% et
l'on commence à voir des sièges arrivé
la même chose il va gagner des sièges il
ya les sièges et bijoux j'étais rendu en
mai soit un peu justement là parce que
j'adore la raison la c il a monté et
quand on regarde ça fait soixante et un
jour qu'on est en campagne d'office à
nous ça nous paraît ya 200 ans la
récession rien n'a plus eu des chiens
qui montrent une progression timide
les progressions d'économies tout de
même dont monsieur un peu et il en train
de se dire je vous entendre vous 3 et
finalement le pari d'une très longue
campagne c'est peut-être possible
jusqu'ici le chantage à moins depuis
quelques jours je commence à me dire que
la plus longue campagne c'est vrai que
c'était parce que ça permet aux
conservateurs aujourd'hui de dépenser
plus les autres mais c'est vrai aussi
que ça a permis aux libéraux et aux
néo-démocrates de d'obsédé l'un par
rapport à l'autre et de se faire
tellement batailles qui ont fini par
oublier celui qui le personnage à
déloger
quand j'entends le les néo-démocrates
dire on va taper plus fort sur justin
trudeau
je me dis est ce que on est en train de
se battre pour la deuxième place ici
parce que de plus en plus ça donne cette
impression
voilà alec écoutez il ya deux
communiqués prêts sur 3 du parti libéral
qui sorte qu'ils attaquent thomas smoker
thomas broquet au début par les premiers
mois de la campagne attaque uniquement
stephen harper mais l'on se tourne vers
justin trudeau pour être capable d'aller
chercher des voies justin trudeau
on est clairement là un effet de
cannibalisme dans les deuxième et
troisième positions qui avantagent
stephen harper le fameux la fameuse
division du vote ne fait on a souvent
parlé présentement elle s'exerce on le
voit très bien dans les sondages et oui
stephen harper peut dépenser plus
longtemps
mais l'un d'eux c'est par ici aussi que
le npd qui était promis puis très bien
très bon premier au début de la campagne
soit sécurité pendant tellement
longtemps que moment donné quand impôts
étaient mineurs souvent dans ta vie
plein npd à dieu c'est pour était en
position de former le gouvernement
souvent il y allait avoir y arriver
quelque chose et leur ordinaire après
est attaquée pendant 60 jours
le mp dit il soufflé la difficulté s'est
fait attaquer par les libéraux s'est
fait attaquer par le bâti conservation
puisqu'ils venant après lui et fameux
bloc départ le blog et stephen harper
lui pendant ça leur fait son petit
bonhomme de chemin et mac de mac
d'office
ça a été très dur pendant les deux
semaines que ça dure et plus personne
n'en parlait des cycles dans une
campagne électorale
présentement on est dans un cycle qui
plus tôt aussi pour le parti
conservateur reste deux semaines et
demie on verra ce qui va se passer mais
il doit pas se plaindre d'être le will
actuellement ils cherchent j'allais
finir par une autre image de base-ball
c'est pas fini tant que ce n'est pas
fini oui c'est pas fini tant que ce
n'est pas fini mais à un moment donné il
ya des tendances qui viennent
s'installer puis la classe la plus
lourde des élections canadiennes depuis
deux ou trois cycles d'élection c'est
qu'il ya deux parties qui se divisent le
vote progressiste de centre gauche et à
gauche et il y en a un seul à droite et
cette tendance là elle jouait commence à
jouer très forts et de pluies vont se
taper dessus mais sur mannequins et
trudeau là l'autre plus ils vont laisser
encore plus de place à main sur un peu
ça c'est c'était l'histoire de la
dernière élection puis de celle d'avant
je crains derrière oui chantier va
monter encore plus parce qu'il m'a déjà
fait remarquer depuis que pierre trudeau
a gagné 1,80 donc depuis cette élection
mais à chaque fois que le parti libéral
a affronté un parti conservateur unifiée
il réussit une seule fois à former un
gouvernement ce n'était pas le matin
c'était minoritaires jean chrétien une
touche alors on oublie ça c'est une
dynamique complète exactement la
division de la droite devant lui puis il
y en a profité comme son égal en profite
mais ne s'imposeront pas ça mais ce nom
mais ce qui pourrait revenir mais là on
a on a 23 jours pour en parler encore on
va avoir le droit à peut-être déjà on se
parlait plus au lendemain messieurs
dames toujours un plaisir de revoir